Hello everyone. Today I'm going to talk about hydrostatic pressure that is in chapter two, pressure distribution in fluid. So later on in chapter, in other chapters, I'll be talking about
I'm going to talk about fluid when it's in motion. When it's motion meaning the particle can be moved in a relatively different speed. But in chapter two, I'm going to talk about either the fluid doesn't fluid at rest.
about fluid at rest or fluid moving in a rigid motion in a rigid motion all particles are moving at the same velocity [Review note: The same linear velocity applies to rigid translation, not rotation; in rigid rotation speed is omega r.]
translation or rotation so and also pressure can be different depending on the depth right so I'm going to talk about how we can determine the pressure distribution in a fluid
And then we are going to talk about whether we can calculate some pressure, some force or moment by those pressure distribution. So the learning topics that we are going to talk about are the
in a static fluid we are recognized a pressure variation and then in a liquid there could be an atmosphere or a river or ocean
We are talking about how pressure is distributed. You may have heard of a U-tube or manometer.
that is a device to measure the pressure in a static fluid system so I'm going to talk about that and then in a submerged flat we are going to
learn how much of the force is exerted on a submerged flat plate, and then buoyancy force, right, buoyancy force, buoyancy force is found by these
the old scientist of Archimedes and we are going to talk about Archimedes two principles so the buoyancy force can be exerted
on a submerged body or floating body. So part submerged, part stuck out of the fluid. So we are going to talk about the buoyancy. And then what if the four
or how much of the pressure or force is generated in a rigid body motion of the fluid. So the pressure that I'm talking about in chapter two.
is a static pressure so a fluid at rest right so fluid is a fluid at rest cannot support shear stress which means that there's no
shear stress in a static fluid no shear stress in a static fluid why is that later on I'll talk more about the shear stress
later I'll talk more about the shear stress, sorry guys, later I will talk more about the shear stress and those shear stress are generated, shear stress is generated by the different velocities
if there is a velocity gradient then there will be a shear stress so this we are assuming a fluid doesn't move at rest so we don't have any relatively different motion between the fluid particle so we are assuming
assuming there is no shear stress then the only thing we can expect is the fluid pressure and there is the normal stress on any plane through a static fluid element
that is called the fluid pressure. Pressure itself is not a force but it creates the force normal to the surface. So if there is a pressure gradient later on I talk about
about a pressure, pressure, pressure and pressure gradient, and it creates a force, normal, the direction of the pressure is normal to the surface, here, and then think
Let's look into this small fluid element. Fluid element is pretty small so you don't have to worry too much about how it is shaped but this is a single
small element that we can consider the pressure in a horizontal, pressure in a horizontal, sorry, it's moving around, pressure in a horizontal location and pressure.
acting on a normal and then pressure acting with arbitrary angle, right? So in that case, we'll see what will be the magnitude of the PX, PZ, MP.
pn. I'm sure in a course of studies, I assume you already learned about the pressure. Pressure is the force per unit. The direction is always normal. And then
it is pointing to the normal to the surface right and then we are assuming small this small fluid element we are
apply the force balance, so from the pressure to have the force on the right hand side, oh my god, I'm so sorry guys, so from the left side,
we have the force of Px and then this small element has the width B into the paper normal to the our screen.
So the surface of this layer
left hand side will be b multiplied into the gx, right? So the force will be acting in this direction will be px multiplied by the delta z and b and then bottom side
the force will be the pressure is a Pz and the area will be the total length of this month that will be the delta x and then depth is a bit likewise
on the upper side the force will be pressure multiplied by the area area will be the length of this slope will be delta s and then width into the
paper will be B, right, B, and to apply the force balance like in terms of the Fx and in terms of the Fy, so in terms of the Fx, we will decompose
this force into a Y component and then X component, right? So this will be the P and X and there will be the P and Y. So in terms of the force echelon,
equilibrium in x direction, we have this much of the px, delta z, b, and then from the force acting on the slanted surface,
we have negative pnx will be the force so this will also be a theta so that will be the
sine theta, right, so there will be Pn delta S, B sine theta, so here sine theta and cosine theta, sine theta will be
delta z over delta s cosine theta will be delta x over delta s so sine theta will be delta z over delta s
okay so delta S, delta S will be zero so that has to be zero and we can cancel out delta ZB, delta ZB in the left hand in first term and second term then what we are going to do
to have is Px is the same as Pn, right? And then in terms of the y direction, we have from the force from the bottom will be
Pz multiplied by the delta xb, and then force from the slanted surface, we have Pn delta Sb cosine theta, right? Then the sign is negative, so my
minus pn, delta s, E, cosine theta will be this month, delta x divided by delta s, and then we have the
elemental weight, right? So this is also pointing downward. So negative rho g multiplied by the half b delta x delta z.
right so here delta s that has to be zero and delta s delta s is a cancelled out and we have the delta xb in all terms so delta xb will be cancelled out delta xb then
the left, what's left, left R, PZ minus PN minus half rho G delta Z, right? So this should be a half, oh, sorry.
If we take the limit of delta z going to zero, that term goes to zero.
limit of if delta z goes to zero, that term goes to zero. So we have Pz equals Pn. So we have Px equal Pn, Pz equal Pn.
So therefore from the force balance we have Px, Pz equals Pn.
So like I said, force is a vector but pressure is not a vector.
and simply it has the direction that is acting upon and then in terms of the you can consider as a vector but this you can consider the magnitude
Px, Pz, Pn, those are exactly the same in a static fluid, right? Because it is in the equilibrium. So two important principles, no pressure change in horizontal direction, in horizontal.
direction, so whenever you want to apply the equilibrium state, then convert pressure into a force, then you can apply the force equilibrium, so no pressure change in horizontal direction, and
only the vertical change in pressure, only in a vertical, only in a vertical change in pressure proportional to the density, gravity, and depth of change, so relatively
density is pretty much the constant throughout the material and the gravity is also constant so mostly the vertical change in pressure is mostly due to the depth of change. So depth change though
So this delta pressure corresponding to depth change is very dramatic in water, not in air much, right?
Okay, so another infinitesimally small fluid element
So whenever we say infinitesimally small, then the length should be noted as a differential, right? dx, dy, and dz. So this is x and this is y.
and this is a G. So for a static fluid, only normal force, only normal force, only normal
force is considered for the static fluid. So if you think about the force acting on the left hand side, there will be the P, DX, DZ. And then we have a force acting to the
right surface, but we have dx, so this is a very small length, but across the dy, we should allow a small changes in a pressure, so
you heard of you learned about the Taylor series right so we assumed the Taylor series up to the first order then the changes in the pressure in the right hand side in this small element
is p plus partial p partial y dy, right? So that is the small variations in p in this small element between the left hand side and y.
right-hand side, so I didn't talk whether this will, how much or how big, or it is the same as the left-hand side pressure, but we have that term, to make the force, we have to multiply by the area, so there will be the dx.
x and dz right so pressure causes pressure or stress normal stress causes causes a net force on a fluid element right but then
like I said what causes a net force so there is not a pressure but then there is the pressure gradient okay gradient I talked about I'm talking about the net force okay
and pressure gradient is a surface force.
So here the same element, so net force in the x direction only.
So if you're talking about x direction is this direction, right?
So
that is the y direction. So if you think about the same for the pressure variation along the x between the back surface and then front surface, then so in the back surface, we can
consider in the back surface, in the back surface like this one, right? In the back, how can I, right? In the back surface, P, there will be the PX.
with px, and then area will be dy, dz, right, dy, dy, dz, I think this is too thick, and front surface, so this is from, for the,
back surface, right, this is a back face, the front surface, we have variation, this is for the front surface, front face, we have
we have variation Px plus I'll just say P because the pressure is the same everywhere so P we have the variation linear
variation in a Taylor series. So there will be partial P, partial X, DX, then area will be DY, DZ. Then this is a force and that is also a force.
force, then the net force in x direction will be, sorry, it should be pointing this direction, right, in the surface, this direction, the front surface, there will be
p dy dz minus p plus partial p partial x dx dy dz right so we can cancel out
single term then we have minus partial p partial x dx dy dz right so that is only in x direction so if we think about the total
net force vector on the element, the F press, press meaning pressure, then we probably have minus dp dx in the x direction, minus dp dy, minus partial p, partial p y in the y direction, and minus
partial p partial z in the z direction.
So if we think about elemental force,
F pressure will be the F pressure.
So if we,
divide dx dy dz for the left hand side then we have we define that as a elemental pressure force and they will be corresponding to the negative
gradient pressures right so if we apply the Newton's law then equilibrium of a force element so this is a general case so we have to consider the pressure force and then
we have to think about the gravity force by the weight right so F F gravity and then we have the if it is in motion so this
I'm so sorry, guys, plus F, viscous, so this is more for the general case, right, general case, so we have the, we have to consider
gravity force, viscous force in addition to the pressure force. So pressure force will be corresponding to the negative gradient pressure and then gravity force is simply rho g, right, the weight.
Plus F_visc; by Newton's law this is rho a. Rho g is the weight per unit volume.
a lot of times in a static fluid we can disregard this F_visc. Now before we further into the hydrostatic pressure I will define a very important
for an definition for the pressure. So we're going to talk about the static pressure. We define gauge pressure, absolute pressure, and then vacuum pressure. So when we are saying gauge pressure,
this pressure measures relative to the atmosphere pressure so atmospheric pressure is taken as a zero reference so here peak gauge is the absolute pressure negative
Fp atm okay so it what it physically what it means is that how much a pressure is above or below atmospheric pressure and absolute pressure we don't consider the atmospheric so
gauge pressure it takes into the atmospheric pressure but for the absolute pressure it doesn't consider the atmospheric so pressure is measured relative to a perfect
vacuum, zero absolute pressure, so absolute pressure is we have to add the PATM, we do consider PATM, right, and then vacuum pressure is used when the, when the,
the absolute pressure is below atmospheric pressure it expresses the amount by which the pressure is below the atmospheric pressure so here P vacuum is P8
tm negative p abs when p abs is smaller than p atm so that is the vacuum so we always assume when so the negative gauge pressure expressed as a positive value
okay so we say vacuum pressure is positive 2 atm which means that oh that vacuum pressure is less than the atm atmospheric pressure [Review note: This illustrative vacuum-pressure value is not a specified physical state. Absolute pressure cannot be negative; the permitted vacuum-pressure deficit depends on the surrounding absolute pressure.]
by two ATM, right? So we have to be careful about those definitions. And then again, let's think about hydrostatic pressure. So if the fluid is at rust,
or at constant velocity which means that like I said viscous force is a zero I told you right why is that viscous force is generated by the relative motion of the fluid particle
Acceleration a equals zero. Then grad p is rho g only. If we disregard F_visc and set rho a equal to zero,
we have only those two terms. Grad p equals rho g. Grad p is the gradient of pressure, with the x, y, and z partial derivatives.
and P will be partial P, partial X, partial P, partial Y, partial P, partial Z and then so Y component should be zero. So rho G, rho G has
the right-hand side rho g, the left-hand side minus the gradient p, rho g will be 0, 0, negative rho g, right, negative rho g.
So partial p, partial z will be negative rho g and we define that as what? Minus rho g and we define that as a
specific weight, gamma, so specific weight is the gamma here, okay, so specific, sorry guys, specific weight is gamma
and then the physical meaning is the weight per unit volume so this is the weight and this is the volume and when do we use a specific weight I told you in the last
last chapter so specific weight is especially useful when we are calculating pressure and force in fluids in hydrostatics the pressure at depth H is P equals gamma
h. So if we multiply height how much you are immersed in a fluid and multiply by the specific weight of that fluid. So specific weight is a unique to
into the water or air or mercury. So if we multiply by the H into the specific weight, then there will be the static pressure.
okay so gamma was rho g so that will be the rho gh so I think it is worthwhile to remember that okay then
pressure distribution so let's assume these types of the container we have and then at the free surface, free surface meaning surface is allowed to move like the ocean wave
so we call it so that we have a contact surface between the air and water but we do define the we do define that as a free surface and then we have a depth one and depth two in a depth one we are considering four locations
and A, B, C, D. So in that case, if that has the same vertical height, right, then, so A, B, C, oh, so these are different. So here, A.
B, C, the same height, then PA equals PB equals PC. So pressure in a continuously distributed uniform static fluid.
it says static it doesn't change and uniform meaning the density is doesn't change right so if that's the case then pressure varies only with what vertical distance
not the horizontal, vertical distance, so that is a very unique characteristics of the hydrostatic pressure, hydrostatic pressure meaning pressure in a static fluid, the pressure is the same
at all points on a given horizontal plane in the fluid, which means the weather pressure at A, pressure B, we do have the horizontal change, but the pressure doesn't change. Pressure increases only with the depth, right?
and then this is not the same as the PD. Why is it? Because it does include it in a mercury. So it has a different specific weight. And then P was what? Pressure 30.
pressure was rho GH or gamma H right so pressure as long as you have the same gamma pressure is directly proportional to the H depth but if the gamma
is different from the water then in a mercury will have the different velocity right so how can you calculate the pressure in this location based on that one so we are going to talk about that [Review note: The quantity under discussion is pressure, not velocity.]
in later. So here, hydrostatic pressure in liquids. So in fluids, we consider liquids is different from the gas. So first, we are talking about the liquids.
Liquids are incompressible, it cannot be compressed, meaning
it is the speed of the fluid is so low compared to the air so it doesn't move at a very high speed right
it could be compressible but we are talking about a typical liquid without any special
process. So typically liquids are incompressible and by the definition of the compressibility, incompressible meaning the density doesn't change. So the constant density.
so if we are like in the previous example if we are thinking about the pressure here and pressure here and pressure here at the same medium whether it is in water or in the mercury
we define two locations in the same medium we define the two locations and P2 minus P1 is the same as the gamma multiplied by the Z2 minus [Review note: Slide 9 gives P2 − P1 = −gamma(z2 − z1); retain the minus sign.]
and then in fact, why is it, this is because the gamma is the same, right, the gamma is the same, we can have this relation and if we express this term,
in terms of the depth, z1 minus z2, there will be P2 over gamma minus P1 over gamma. So here we define pressure head.
pressure head, this form, P over gamma form, so pressure head, we define as H or Z, the height, that is the P over specific weight, that is
P over rho g. So that is the definition of the pressure head. And what it says is that the height of a column of a given fluid that would produce a certain pressure at its base due to its own weight.
okay so you can consider later like this type of the tube right it is filled with mercury and the pressure the length of this
column to represent the PA here, then how much of the weight, how much of the height is required. So that H is called a pressure head. So let's
Let's assume river, lakes or ocean. So this is an example to apply the hydrostatic pressure property. So let's assume that this is a ocean.
and we consider that as a z1 so in terms of what should be the z1 and what should be the one state and what should be the two state it doesn't matter it is all it's up to you guys so fix one
one location, z1 is a zero, then above it should be positive, below it should be negative, as long as you are consistent, it doesn't matter whether you take Z1 or
Z2, so at the Z1, Z1 is the free surface that contacts, that water contacts with the air, so we say Z1 equals zero, this is assumed
assumption, and P1 is a PA at the free surface, right? So we do have C equals zero and P equals PA, and I want to calculate, let's assume that this is a two state, just, we just,
this is state 2 and this is state 3 and we are going to calculate the pressure at these two locations using the hydrostatic assumption then at this location
equation, P2 minus P1 equal, we are in the water medium, right, so gamma, water, so gamma, water, and then Z2,
z2 here is negative H, right, sorry, minus here, right, so here there is a negative sign, so minus H minus Z1 will be zero, so we have P
P2 will be P1 plus gamma water H here. So gamma water is given as 9,790 newton per
meter cubed multiplied by the h was what h was uh oh it wasn't specified so just uh h it just used this symbol so p1 is a pa right
pressure, so P here, pressure will be Pa plus H gamma water, and then I want to apply the hydrostatic relation between the Z1 and Z3, but the medium here,
The medium here is air, so P3 minus P1 equals minus gamma_air times (z3 minus z1).
P1 is Pa. Gamma_air is 11.8, and z3 is b, while z1 is zero, so P3
is Pa minus 11.8 b. This is the same as the figure. These are two examples, but we have to use the consistent
the gamma this can be applied this formulation can be applied when you have the gamma is the same right when you can apply that in a medium
where the game I know what it is this is the bug with the pdf annotator this software is called the pdf annotator and it has some bugs so so this relation can be applied on
only at the same gamma okay okay then some example using the hydrostatic pressure relation we have the this is the mercury barometer from the figure like the one
you see in a thermostat right in your room so here um so did we say this is the one state and this is a state one and this is the state
state two, on the surface, that is the state two, from the figure with the, and then here, Mercury has a very low vapor pressure, so P1 is almost zero, so at the,
equals zero, at Z1 equals H, and at the contact surface, free surface, P2 is atmospheric pressure, but Z2 equals zero. What is the corresponding H? So if we are
applying the hydrostatic relation hydrostatic pressure relation between the state two and state one where the mercury is a field then P2 minus P1
P2 minus P1 equals minus gamma mercury Z2 minus Z1, right? So here P2 is PA, P2 is PA.
okay and P1 is a zero and minus gamma mercury is given as this one minus gamma mercury and Z2 is a zero and Z1 is H right so therefore
H will be Pa over atmospheric pressure divided by the gamma mercury. So it will be 0.761 meter.
So this hydrostatic, again, this hydrostatic relation can be applied within the same continuous medium
Now let's look into the gas. Gases are compressible
like the gases are compressible. Then we can apply the ideal-gas law P equals rho RT and if we differentiate [Review note: Use the hydrostatic equation and substitute rho=p/(RT); do not obtain dp/dz by differentiating the ideal-gas law alone.]
with respect to z, then dp dz equals minus rho g, and then from where p was, at the same time, p equal,
minus gamma h and there was rho g h right sorry rho g h so if we take the dg dp dg
the negative rho g then minus p over rt sorry minus p over rt rt g right so
this negative corresponds to the pressure increases when you are going down right in a water or in a water in a water or let's say we have
the water or the air so if you go down the g is a negative or in even the air when the altitude is decreasing your pressure increases right so because of that
when you are differentiating with respect to Z, we have the negative sign here. So DPZ equals negative rho G and using the ideal-gas law, rho is replaced by the negative P over [Review note: Density is positive p/(RT); the minus sign belongs to dp/dz=−rho g.]
RRT and if we move the P to the left-hand side, DZ to the right-hand side, we have that relation and we can integrate the left-hand side
side by DP and integrate the right hand side by the DZ. Then if we assume T equal T0, that is the isothermal atmospheric model or linear temperature drop model. So that is more realistic to our current.
and as a scenario. So T equal to T zero minus BZ. Z is the altitude, B is the lapse rate, meaning how much the temperature is decreased and B.
altitude goes up right so this is a simple p2 equal for the lean isothermal atmospheric model so that is a very unrealistic but for simplicity if we assume that one then the simple integration will give us
of the P2, when linear temperature drop, then replace T by the T0 negative minus Bz, and then carry out the
integration that we have that one where rho can be written as this one. So this one you don't have to memorize but the only thing you have to memorize is that you have to worry is hydrostatic.
pressure relation in liquid or a gas right so here so using that hydrostatic relation people made a device
of manometry. A static column of one or more liquids can be used to measure the pressure difference.
pressure difference so for example this is the U tube or manometer this is a one example of the manometer and you have the
one end is closed and one end is open and we have some liquid inside like the mercury or it could be anything oil and open side
right this should be same as the atmospheric pressures right so this contact surface this is state 2 P2 is almost a PA and so this is when with this known pressure
then we can calculate the pressure at this location and also at PA as well right so some example a simple manometer so I want to calculate the
pressure here. Calculate pressure at the inside. What is the pressure? So that is our question. And then how many states do we have? We have state A here, state A.
and then we have a state one so this is the state one state one so two meaning calculate the pressure at the state one and this one is
and this one is another state, state two. This is the, sorry, this is the state two, this is the, this one is the state two, right?
state two here.